hi
this is dr gregory sadler i'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason i o
where we put philosophy into practice
i've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and i find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
i come in
to help students and lifelong learners
i've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube
many viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on one core concept from
an important philosophical text i hope
you find it useful as well
norman bowie in his essay a conscient
approach to business ethics applies the
third formulation of kant's categorical
imperative to business organizations and
just as a little reminder for those who
aren't all that up on their [ __ ] how
does the third formulation go so act as
if you were a member of an ideal kingdom
of ends in which you were both subject
and sovereign at the same time there's
other formulations of it as well found
in his work it's a little bit more
you know complex than the first two
formulations but what are some of the
key ideas here
we are subject and sovereign at the same
time subject means that we
have the rules imposed upon us and we
have to follow them sovereign means we
get to make the rules now it's not just
us
but everybody else involved in the
organization a little bit later on in
this section
bowie will say that a cochin views an
organization whether it's a business
organization or anything else as a moral
community each member of the
organization stands in a moral
relationship to all the others on the
one hand managers should respect the
humanity and all the persons in the
organization on the other hand each
individual should view the organization
other than purely instrumentally not
just as a place for them to get what
they want to extract their value out of
it they have to think of other people
involved and so
part of what this means
according to bowie is that the rules
governing the organization itself rules
policies procedures decisions practices
need to be
able
to be endorsed by all that means that
there's gonna have to be some measure as
he points out of democratic decision
making it can't just be all entirely top
down and he's going to point out as well
that
one of the chief implications of kant's
ethics is a moral critique of
authoritarian hierarchical
organizational structures that would be
a problem
now he
says that we have to consider the
interests of all affected stakeholders
and that's going to be one of the very
first of his principles so let's let's
talk about that he says the business
firm should consider interests of all
affected stakeholders in
any decision it makes now why does he
say that this is a straightforward
requirement for any moral theory that
takes respect for a person seriously
this would also be something that a
utilitarian could get behind her a
virtue ethicist could get behind as well
the second one he says
though the firm should have those
affected by the firm's rules and
policies participate
in the determination of those rules and
policies before they are implemented
this goes a little bit further this is
in some respects
quite
revolutionary in in requiring that those
who are being affected particularly the
employees
by the rules and policies have some role
in the discussion
it doesn't mean that they have to
absolutely decide or that they have a
veto on everything but they have to be
permitted to take part in that before
the rules are implemented now how then
do we decide how to you know work out
what rules to have
the the third and fourth principle
really
figure into that so he says that it
should not be the case that for all
decisions the interests of one
stakeholder automatically take priority
this could be tempting if we say upper
management or the owners are the
stakeholder for whom you know everything
ultimately uh you know they're the last
resort you could say um they're the ones
that that everything ultimately has to
to
cater to and everybody else is kind of
second nature second class citizens if
if you like for that that would be a
fundamental problem
so bowie says that no you can't do it
like that
it could be that in many cases the
interest of one stakeholder would take
priority it could be that we take the
automatic out of that and there's some
sort of deliberative process where say
the workers would say well you know this
person did put up all the money and they
do have all the contacts so maybe it is
okay that we give them priority but
there there cannot be an automatic
assumption that that will be the case
the fourth one rules out deciding things
on purely utilitarian grounds he says
when a situation arises where it appears
that the interest of one set of
stakeholders
must be subordinated to the interests of
another set of stakeholders which is
very commonly the case is it not in
business decisions
that decision should not be made solely
on the grounds that there's a greater
number of stakeholders in one group than
another i think that we could actually
add to this and say that
perhaps we should also rule out
one group being given automatic priority
on the basis of prestige
or social standing in some respect
so
this is important because it says again
you can't just like do a poll
or see
who's being affected on utilitarian
grounds you have to actually think this
through on conscient grounds
the fifth one pretty straightforward for
conscient capitalism no business rule or
practice can be adopted which is
inconsistent with the first two
formulations of the categorical
imperative so you know for example the
practice of renegotiating contracts
under duress clearly a violation of
both the first and second formulation of
the categorical imperative can't do that
right
requiring employees to not take
overtime hours
when when there's more work to be done
so not allowing them to bill overtime
hours as overtime hours doing sort of
creative payroll accounting that would
be ruled out that would violate both
again the first and second formulation
of the categorical imperative and we can
think of many other examples as well
the last two rules have to do with
the requirements for the
firm you could say outside of
the firm itself although it would also
include that so the sixth one says every
profit making firm has a limited but
genuine duty of beneficence and here
he's got a really interesting discussion
about this that's worth looking at he
says
if corporations have benefited from
society they have a duty of beneficence
to society in return so there's an if
then
and then he says corporations have
indeed benefited how society protects
corporations by providing means for
enforcing business contracts it provides
infrastructure which allows the
corporation to function one of these
include roads sanitation facilities
police and fire protection an educated
workforce is part of that very
infrastructure and he says few would
argue that corporate taxes pay the full
cost of these benefits this is
particularly acute in our time when some
of the largest corporations pay very
little corporate taxes because of the
way they have used the code so that's
that's an important issue they notice he
doesn't say universal beneficence it's a
limited
requirement and it's up to the company
where they want to devote those
beneficent acts or services or products
or anything like that but they really do
have a duty under under kant's view
then the the seventh one he says this is
a procedural principle and he says every
business firm must establish procedures
to ensure that relations among
stakeholders are governed by rules of
justice now notice he's not just saying
every
firm must run its internal discussions
or its external uh you know engagements
in such a way as they meet the
requirements of rules of justice goes a
little bit further than that every firm
must establish procedures
they have to set down some sort of rules
some sort of policy that makes sure
that that justice is actually going to
be
observed in the relation between the
different stakeholders this is central
to the
company being a moral community and it's
central to this this formulation where
we are both subject and sovereign and we
have to create rules that show us how
things are going to be done so this is
how the third formulation of the
categorical imperative would apply to
business organizations according to
bowie